لم تعد اكثر المناطق ازدحاما كما كانت
مركز العاصمه دمشق شبه خال من حركه
السيارات وذلك بعد انقطاع شبهتام
للمحروقات اثر على جميع مناطق سيطره
النظام
العديد من السوريين الى استخدام ما توفر
من مركبات لجات حكومه النظامي لتعطيل
مؤسساتها التي اصبحت تعمل على فترات
متقطعه في جيران ياتي ضمن خطه تقشفيات
وفي السوق المحليه رفعت الحكومه السعر لتر
البنزين الى نحو خمسه الاف ليره كما ضاعفت
سعر لتر المازوت ومع ندره المحروقات زادت
اسعارها في السوق الموازيه الى سته
امثالها بل اكثر
والنتيجه انعكاس تاثير نقص المحروقات سلبا
على جميع القطاعات الخدميه
وكانت الوحدات الكرديه استحودت في مناطق
سيطرتها شمال الشرقيه سوريا على معظم
مصادر النفط لتلقى حكومه النظام السوري
استيراد المحروقات من ايران لكن العقوبات
الاقتصاديه على طيران تعرقل وصولها فضلا
عن ان حكومه النظام لا تستطيع سداد ثمنها
وتقدر حاجه مناطق سيطره النظام من
سبعه الاف طن من المازوت وخمسه الاف طن من
البنزين يوميا
وفي سوق الصرف تواصل الليره وطها الحاد
تخطى الدولار في السوق الموازيه مستوى سته
الاف ليره وانخفض متوسط دخل الموظفين الى
ما يعادل 20 دولارا فقط في الشهر
وبحسب دراسات فهو لا يغطي نفقات العائله
لايام قليله تحتاج الى 280 دولارا في
المتوسط لتامين متطلبات المعيشه في حين
تظهر احصائيات الامميه ان 80% من السوريين
يعانون انعدام الامن الغذائي وان معدل
الفقري تخطى 90%
ورغم انخفاض وتيره الحرب في سوريا فان
الوضع الاقتصاديه اخذ في التدهور مع
ارتباط الملفين الاقتصادي والسياسي فهناك
رفض الامريكي اوروبي لتقديم اي مساعدات مع
التمسك بالابقاء على العقوبات